[Musique]
regardez ça vous voyez qu'ils gagnent de l'
argent avec le jeune homme oh boy
une de ces personnes m'a en fait dit
qu'ils avaient gagné des milliers de dollars sur moi
j'étais comme bien
[Musique]
né au Texas et je n'arrêtais pas de m'arrêter à New
Orléans parce que c'était le seul endroit
où je pouvais encore être, vous savez,
ouvert d'esprit et amusant et énergique à propos de
la vie, mais je n'avais pas à m'arrêter à deux
heures du matin ou à rester à l'intérieur
du bar avec mon verre ou tout le  des choses
qui sont un peu des
trucs typiques de la culture américaine ici nous sommes c'est un peu
la pluie de ce matin que vous voyez ici
c'est le truc à propos de la Nouvelle-Orléans vous
savez que l'eau a tendance à traîner un
peu dans chaque coffre à la Nouvelle-
Orléans vous pouvez trouver des hauts sont
[Applaudissements]
si vous n'êtes pas pour moi, je voudrais vous souhaiter la
bienvenue dans ma merveilleuse
[Musique] [
Musique]
jouez-vous toujours ensemble ouais donnez-
lui un chèque maintenant
merci
[Musique]
aussi c'est pourquoi j'avais l'habitude de  jouer avec un
tube de graisse monsieur
James et tout le monde en tant qu'enfant de quatre ou cinq
ans
deux jours frère samedi dimanche nous avons
fait environ quatre cents dollars de paix
et gémit Wow chaque week-end il y a une
belle chose c'est une belle chose
dont nous l'avons vu venir  vous
savez d'un enfant jouant dans les rues
jouant ici c'est notre scène
ici c'est
pourquoi j'ai appris la plupart de mes premières
musiques n'avez-vous pas fait un peu de claquettes
[Musique]
il mélange le truc de groupe de branche avec du
rock avec du funk avec  jazz c'est cool Ivan
et sa famille étaient les gens qui ont mis
le funk dans ma vie ouais sa famille a
aidé à créer le son que nous connaissons comme la
Nouvelle-Orléans et pour lui d'en faire partie,
j'ai la chance de pouvoir être
autour d'une famille et Ivan étant juste à côté
de lui en le regardant jouer, je suis capable de
m'imprégner de quelque chose et de le mettre avec
mon groupe et différentes choses à la Nouvelle-Orléans
absolument et c'est un peu vrai comme dans
certains quartiers, sorte de race plus
certains types de  de petites variations sur
le truc de la Nouvelle-Orléans comme si vous aviez beaucoup
de batteurs ouais qui venaient probablement d'en
haut, vous savez que vous n'aviez pas de cornistes
de la 6e guerre de la région de Treme,
vous savez que beaucoup de chats
jouaient de la guitare de la Civil  La guerre
ouais vraiment comme ça et puis vous avez
des cancers qui ont juste joué tout ce qu'ils
essayaient de jouer partout mais c'est en quelque sorte
un mélange et un match vous savez
et donc nous apprenons tous les uns des autres
[Musique]
J'avais l'habitude d'aller à ça  église juste là
en ce moment nous sommes toujours intermédiaires donc j'ai
été baptisé dans cette église je
vivais dans cette maison
13h15 et puis plus tard nous avons vécu dans cette
maison vous avez déjà entendu parler d'un james black
ils vivaient dans la maison à côté  porte
le drame james black ouais c'est une
chose à propos des portefeuilles et chaque bloc il
y a un individu célèbre que vous connaissez
quelqu'un qui a déjà été influencé ou d'
une manière ou d'une autre ou juste le
groupe de quartier vous savez que la musique a
toujours été vous savez la force motrice
dans  la culture des portefeuilles que vous connaissez et
sera toujours
[Musique]
donc c'est la maison donc nous avions l'habitude de
répéter dans cette arrière-salle ici ouais
vous pouvez probablement monter sur les marches
et le voir ouais nous avions l'habitude de répéter
ici je veux dire  nous jouons
ensemble maintenant, en fait, j'avais 36
ans, je jouais ensemble 30 douzaines de
[musique]
une douzaine est géniale nous écoutons leurs
disques encore et encore et encore
quand nous avons commencé la rivière
[la musique]
n'a pas de force  influence sur moi
et la renaissance dès le début
vers 1982, j'enseignais à l'école,
j'enseignais à Carmen et à beaucoup d'
autres gars de la renaissance, il y
avait de petits enfants, vous savez, ils ont eu la
renaissance ensemble et leur permettraient vraiment
pour mûrir s'ils ont commencé à résoudre
pour nous à la Glass House, nous allions à
la Glass House uptown et regardions
Dirty Dozen jouer tous les lundis soirs, hé
mon président cinq ou six ans ou
quelque chose que nous avons commencé à voyager, puis
au point où les outils ont commencé
de plus en plus longtemps nous ne pouvions pas
revenir le lundi alors ils ont embauché la
renaissance pour nous remplacer c'est la
tradition de la Nouvelle-Orléans un mauvais après-midi
vous savez tout le chemin ouais nous tous nous nous
entrelaçons tous vous savez c'est comme un vrai
réseau de musiciens  et tout comme ça,
il était juste un grand joueur avec nous qu'il
ne pouvait même pas atteindre maintenant c'est son heure
hey qu'est-ce que tu fais ici allez
encore et encore et
encore et c'est ouais
c'est l'énergie des DJ qui ont créé
bounce en 1987 Mannie Fresh DJ ERV ces
gars l'ont fait pour les danseurs pas
beaucoup de gens qui s'assoient et
écoutent juste de la musique bounce dès qu'elle
arrive sur tout le monde  tu sais sauter
et les filles attrapent des choses et
ça se passe très vite de cette façon la musique la plus
populaire de la ville maintenant
[Musique]
et je mettrai les clics pour les chansons je
ne veux pas utiliser mon clic oh tu dois
avoir  un nouvel équipement voit Gus en avoir envie
du poulet dedans de la
sauce piquante des crevettes de la saucisse
fumée un ragoût de viande quelque part là-
dedans ça n'a pas l'air bien 10 minutes
non je n'ai pas 10 environ 500 autres il suffit de
le mettre là-dedans
Musique]
[Musique]
d'accord,
tu étais incroyable à Lafayette oh c'était
merveilleux ça - l'un de mes
points forts dieu ouais merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup tu as l'air fabuleux
c'est le seul magasin de musique que nous avons
et  vendre de vrais CD il y a l'un des seuls
endroits qu'il nous reste
peut-être qu'il y a de la crème
nous vendons la plupart de nos nouvelles toute cette musique
et vous pouvez trouver ici de la musique que vous
ne trouverez pas sur Internet vous ne
la trouverez dans
aucun autre magasin
je  compte avec le public
[Musique]
tout le monde veut me rabaisser
[Musique] [
Musique]
yo vraiment Trombone Shorty Je suis désolé vous avez tous
vraiment des problèmes
Je connaissais sa mère avant sa naissance, ce
qui signifie que maman et son père étaient de bons amis
sa mère  et papa salut mon Rebirth Brass Band
lors de notre premier défilé de deuxième ligne peut-être 15
ans avant la naissance de Trombone Shorty,
puis j'ai vu sa mère, je tiens le coup
[Musique]
déplacez des trucs autour de ma camionnette merdique si
vous me voyez faire quelque chose de mal  il n'y
a pas beaucoup de lois ici quand il s'agit de
conduire en quelque sorte libre de faire ce que vous voulez faire
garder la fraîcheur La Nouvelle-Orléans est tout
au sujet du bar du quartier le bar dans lequel
je joue tous les samedis est à deux rues de
là  rue, vous pouvez
voir que cette rue a comme un très joli
comme de très jolis arbres au milieu
et tout ce qu'ils essaient de déplacer,
ils essaient de fermer tous les bars
ici afin qu'ils puissent en faire une belle
avenue comme ça  que les gens
voudront vivre dans les blancs vous
savez en ce moment c'est assez violent et
un peu fou dans le sens où vous savez que cette zone
ici nous essayons de la garder hors
du ring
- court pour vous - nous allons je veux acheter
musique tu as de la nouvelle ne vois pas ceux-ci vont
maintenant me brancher
mon nom est Jesse James Je fais partie du
numéro 5 ta famille tu es dans le
feu negra ici probablement l'un des seuls
labels de disques qui tache encore après
Katrina  ils vendent des chaussures ils vendent de la musique
il y a un bon endroit pour obtenir des CD bounce un
bon succès des CD hip-hop locaux
Toutes sortes de voies commerciales de Rhapsody pour équilibrer
le R&B et c'est Chris Young et il
gère différents artistes plusieurs
artistes c'est tellement difficile d'obtenir ça
répétition d'être le meilleur rappeur en
nous parce qu'il y en a trop, la
Nouvelle-Orléans devient réalité et un rappeur est
tellement de pur talent et beaucoup de choses
passeront inaperçues parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas mettre en place
leur structure sur le plan commercial
certaines personnes  je ne veux rien avoir
à voir avec quoi que ce soit dans l'industrie
et il se trouve qu'ils font partie des
personnes qui s'assoient sur des rapports faisant état d'une
quantité incroyable de talents, mais ils essaient de
les convaincre que vous savez que
s'impliquer dans votre carrière est important  et
prendre comme tout cela faire un travail très dur
pour que cela se produise à la Nouvelle-Orléans
cela ne fonctionne pas vraiment comme ça comme le
talent seul suffit pour certaines personnes
ayant juste le talent et il est difficile d'
aimer naviguer qui veut qui veut
travailler ça  dur, vous connaissez quelqu'un comme
Lil Wayne, vous savez qu'il y a une raison pour laquelle
il est sur cent cinquante nouvelles chansons par
an parce qu'il n'arrête jamais de travailler.
Les gens de la Nouvelle-Orléans peuvent être
assez talentueux pour le faire, mais
ils ne veulent pas tous travailler aussi dur et
essayer de comprendre qui peut c'est la
partie la plus difficile de
l'argent sur le bois pendant que tu es fou si
tes garçons ne soufflent pas pendant que tu es occupé j'ai
un nouveau disque que je ne connaissais pas pour le moment
il est exclusif personne n'a jamais entendu
[Musique  ]
parce que ce disque hier soir mais comme
dans ma
[musique]
parfois je trouve le refrain
parfois il trouve un refrain tu
sais je ne sais juste pas les couplets et tout
ce que nous faisons en laissant pour la musique du feu
c'est pourquoi j'ai été nommé ce n'est rien  pourquoi
tout voulait être viré dans le
sens où tu sais bien comme tu sais que le
feu est si bon qu'il fait beaucoup de
travail préparatoire ne te méprends pas parce que
tu sais que je l'appelle le plug man c'est
comme si tu le savais
[Musique]
ça  était vraiment magique de pouvoir être
dans ce quartier c'est là que
tout a commencé ici cette maison Kermit
Ruffins vivait autour de là mon frère ma
famille Rebirth Brass Band vivait
au coin de la rue Santa Ana c'est
pourquoi ils ont commencé au coin de la rue
il y a un  quartier musical c'est comme ça
tout le monde est musical ici
et tous les musiciens mon cousin Terrence
Andrews il vivait là-bas avec la
fanfare des petits coquins donc c'était
toujours de la musique autour voir même les gros tuba
il est toujours là avec nous donc voulait un
gros tuba
[Musique  ]
salut monsieur.  jereth comment tu vas
je vais bien oui je t'aime aussi merci
mr.  Jereth j'ai apprécié
[Musique]
voir que tous les mercredis soirs nous avons
la garniture d'une fanfare qu'ils jouent ici
et c'est oncle Benny sur une caisse claire
et nous venons de perdre nous venons de perdre un
grand-oncle I&L avec la garniture une
fanfare à la basse  tambour nous venons de le perdre
merci chose préférée c'est le
seul endroit où nous venons tous les mercredis
c'est vrai nous
avions l'habitude de nous installer ici avec le
barbecue nourrir tout le
quartier et de la musique gratuite toute la nuit
ici nous avions tous l'habitude de jouer juste
jam out  oh vraiment
ouais comme un âne tu vas bien
tu as l'air bien tout ce
quartier va gronder à 300
personnes dans la rue c'est fou comme une
scène de film musiciens Shannon Powell
Kermit Ruffins Reaper frère tout
et maintenant tu le regardes et c'est vide
il y a  rien ce gars il dort dans
le cimetière c'est là qu'il vit dans
la rue au centre il dort sur
la grille bien Katrina la grosse tempête que nous avons
eu en 2005 et en août et tout le monde nous
étions tellement habitués à vivre d'une certaine manière et
juste tout était tout  bon pour nous et
un jour avec la tempête venait de
tout anéantir et quand nous sommes rentrés en
ville, vous avez eu beaucoup de prix abusifs et
certaines des personnes qui étaient ici qui
vivaient dans différentes maisons et
tout ce que je pouvais me permettre
ils ne pouvaient tout simplement pas le faire, cela n'est pas
revenu naturellement, il y a des
histoires de gens comme cette
fille, Ephraim, bien que j'aie oublié un [ __ ], vous
savez, elle est sortie sur le porche après que
Katrina soit passée, le soleil sortait
tout avait l'air vraiment sympa et puis
tout  d'un coup, elle a levé les yeux dans la rue
et elle a vu de l'eau arriver, vous savez, au
moment où elle est entrée dans sa maison pour
dire à son mari que l'eau était aussi haute
que la poche au moment où ils sont tous les deux
rentrés pour attraper des choses qu'ils
pouvaient '  t sortir bien qu'ils soient
entrés dans l'eau et en
moins d'une heure, l'eau avait
atteint 25 pieds, ils étaient ils
feraient un trou dans le
toit pour se sauver, ils devaient
monter sur le toit de toute façon et  dit-elle alors
qu'elle était sur le toit le lendemain,
c'est à ce moment-là que les grenouilles et les insectes et tout
cet espace essayant de sortir de l'
eau entrent dans la maison, elle a donc dû
les renverser et tous comme ça se
protéger parce qu'elle était  être
infesté de toutes sortes d'
animaux différents qui y ont survécu
ainsi que des insectes et des grenouilles et des trucs comme
ça des serpents
donc c'était mauvais tout autour d'ici le lac
a ajouté
[Musique] [
Musique]
comme vous pouvez le voir de mon voisin il était
sous l'eau  il était sous l'eau et il
ne reviendra pas il est à Baton Rouge
il a juste dû nager dans un autre océan
tu sais ce gars n'est pas revenu il ne
reviendra pas cette maison a été démolie et
j'étais juste
il a commencé à
réparer ce qu'il a fait hé Chrissy allez
Chrissy
en va assez j'étais en tournée avec Lenny
Kravitz je suis rentré à la maison et deux ou trois
jours à la maison nous avons reçu ce gros
avertissement de tempête et je suis sorti de la ville
quelques heures  avant qu'ils
n'atterrissent, je devais retourner en tournée, donc c'était
une chose étrange pour moi parce que nous avions
des membres de la famille que nous ne pouvions pas attraper oh
il ne pouvait pas bien aussi et nous ne pouvions pas
le joindre et je devais y aller  de retour en tournée
et de terminer ce que nous faisions
Oh Katrina l'eau est montée jusqu'à la dent
en haut de ce toit là ouais
alors tout en bas a été anéanti
inondé tous les souvenirs que j'avais
récupérés du monde entier
tout ce qui était en bas  anéanti
et après avoir volé ma tête Oh un arbre seul
Remorque FEMA ici pendant environ deux
ans Remorque FEMA vous savez que c'était
inconfortable mais c'est ce que c'était
mes voisins ici cette maison était la
loi mais ils l'avaient élevée mais quand
le fort est venu l'eau était sur le
toit vous savez quand elle
était élevée parce que c'est
la nature de la Nouvelle-Orléans nous aimons Venise
maintenant tôt ou tard vous savez que nous devrons
trouver un moyen de coexister avec le
l'eau est bonne Dexter tu connais chaque maison
parce que ça vient ça viendra ouais tu sais
même après la tempête je n'ai même jamais
envisagé de partir tu sais que je n'ai jamais
voulu aller nulle part je n'ai jamais voulu être
ailleurs j'ai toujours su que
je revenais et que je réparais  et vous
savez, en rentrant à la maison, vous savez avant
la tempête, il y avait des gens qui n'avaient jamais
quitté le Ninth Ward, c'était une grande différence.
Katrina a forcé les gens à sortir et l'
a emmené.  moi ici après que tous les
parents et les proches soient allés
ailleurs, c'était la camionnette et Baton Rouge est à
soixante miles de là, il y a un bus
qui vous emmène pour dix
dollars cinq heures dans chaque sens, vous savez qu'il y
avait tellement d'avantages à juste  reste
là moins de drame je n'ai pas à
travailler mais si j'ai un bateau ou pas si
quelqu'un a volé mon bateau je dois m'inquiéter
avec tu sais dormir une nuit
et commencer à flotter pendant que je dors
tu sais que je peux toujours cuisiner  la même nourriture
tu sais tu sais ça ici tu
sais pour Louis Armstrong ici il était à
la maison des garçons de Milne
de cette façon il les a appris gratuitement c'était une
maison de garçons ici les garçons
ouais ils s'appellent The Waifs
nous appelons ça 928 sous l'
intestat
c'est  pourquoi tous les gens traînent
oh ouais
comme moi quand j'étais enfant
et c'est mon frère comme James juste là
mec,
nous évitons les ennuis du bloc M du Milner
et je connais tout le monde, de
l'arbre Ness à cet arbre, c'est ce qui fait une
communauté que vous connaissez d'accord, ne le laissez pas vous
mordre les doigts comme vous le
savez, mettez-le bien, rien ne suffit de
le laisser tomber  si vous le tenez au-dessus de sa tête, il
lèvera la tête, vous saurez à propos de
cet
appareil vocal que vos proches vous rendront
sur mon argent prenez une fille de la
haute joaillerie sainte et c'est ma fille et
et ayez un fou
je  Je n'ai que ce nombre de disques maintenant, je me suis
débarrassé de presque tout ce que j'avais
avant que nous ayons fait quelques
disques vinyles pour des artistes rebondissants ouais c'est
un Big Freedia un Satori 12 pouces que j'ai
fait avec eux avec un disque punk  label
d'Austin,
je suis un terme d'argot positif pour un enfant gay, ce
qui rend tout cela encore plus
ironique que nous travaillions avec un label punk
et que les enfants homosexuels sont appelés des
rappeurs punks avec lesquels je travaille ici à la Nouvelle-
Orléans quand ils jouent dans un noir  Le club
compte 1 500 personnes et seulement 10% d'entre eux
sont homosexuels, vous savez que les rappeurs homosexuels ou transgenres
sont les réussites culturelles dominantes de
cette ville dans leur
propre ville, c'est du jamais vu. Je ne sais pas
si quelque chose comme une très bonne musique rebondissante n'existe à
peu près  sur les mp3 maintenant
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de disques il n'y a pas de
cassettes c'est juste que vous allez au
magasin du coin ils n'ont même pas de magasins de disques
alors vous allez au magasin du coin et il
y a un gars dans le parking et il
ouvre son coffre et  vous lui achetez des CD
et les artistes eux-mêmes n'en tirent jamais d'
argent et les producteurs de
la musique n'en tirent jamais d'argent
et c'est ainsi que cela fonctionne, les gens
le font simplement parce qu'ils l'aiment et
ils continuent
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] c'était
un enfant dans lequel j'ai toujours voulu
pouvoir être comme galactic et Neville
Brothers et jouer à certains moments de
l'année que Ben a probablement rencontré  moi quand j'avais
trois ou quatre ans et que le trim c'est
beaucoup de temps pour le trim avec
la fanfare des petits coquins c'était un
groupe de mes cousins ​​et des membres de la famille
là-bas et moi et Ben jouons
ensemble depuis que je suis né  Je suppose que j'ai
eu de la chance, comment n'avez-vous pas pu oublier
[Music]
c'est un tel honneur pour moi parce que quand
vous êtes capable de jouer House of Blues et que vous
vendez, c'est aussi un autre niveau que
vous avez atteint dans la ville de la Nouvelle-
Orléans  c'est une bénédiction de pouvoir faire
ça c'est un endroit formidable car il
attire beaucoup d'actes nationaux mais nous
faisons la plupart de notre sale boulot chez Tipitina's
Tipitina est un peu hors des
sentiers battus c'est dans le
quartier français alors peut-être  cet endroit pourrait attirer
la clientèle pourrait tirer un peu plus
de l'économie touristique alors que
Tipitina est plus une destination ouais
tu n'iras pas juste à pied chez tina
tu dois aller
[Musique]
pour galactique c'est notre club à domicile qui est
vraiment à peu près  le seul endroit où nous jouons
oui
galactique tu sais il faut juste les voir
en direct et Ben est toujours vraiment innovant
tu sais et la musique et le spectacle et comment
les choses se déroulent c'est juste une de ces
choses incroyables que tu dois voir en direct
et j'ai encore beaucoup de  eux aussi je
n'ai tout simplement pas encore l'argent pour faire les lumières
La Nouvelle-Orléans ce soir,
ce sont des performances de drag
par des artistes de drag de l'extérieur de la ville,
je pense que c'est un peu fou ici, il y a
certainement eu beaucoup de violence dans
le passé et vous savez beaucoup de
combats de parking et des trucs comme ça mais c'est
un calme  un peu et je ne
reste jamais jusqu'à la toute fin, c'est-à-dire avec
toute cette nana à terre, tu sais si tu
pars comme juste avant que ce soit fini,
généralement tout va bien, bienvenue à la
fin de ta carrière maintenant le début de ma
chienne je suis Nikki Oh Nikki à  être la
[Musique]
Je suis vraiment bon avec certaines règles et
des trucs comme ça comme le mettre en place le mettre en place aux
gros seins le faire apparaître par les gros seins le faire apparaître
derrière des choses comme ils ne se maquillent pas
si heureux de  être reconnaissant mais ce ne
sont pas nécessairement des mots que vous connaissez donc
comme utiliser une voix comme si c'était juste un
instrument
encore une fois gros gras je reprends le
projet je suis Rose tu en connais une autre
comme moi tu sais donc tu sais ici mon sac
donc c'est comme un quotidien ils me soutiennent tu
sais et si tu joues avec moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[  Applaudissements]
comme vraiment très amical si vous
êtes qui vous êtes un gros idiot mais c'est
comme si le Sud était fondamentalement plein de
portes comme vous pourriez aussi bien dire que
le sud est la capitale du gaydom
parce que nous '  re comme partout ici, nous
avons des hypothèques dans les rues, ils le font
maintenant dans la ville, mais c'est comme unifier pour
moi des choses comme tout le monde, tout le
monde pourrait rebondir, la Nouvelle-Orléans
se trouve être vraiment vraiment
comprendre quel butin ils secouent leur
conseil d'administration est leurs secrétaires c'est un
penses-tu qu'ils ont des épaules
comme paralysé comme si cela venait
si naturellement c'est comme si vous saviez que vous le faites
si bien  le
plus grand musical
riche du quartier, vous n'aviez pas d'autre
choix que d'apprendre la musique et quand vous
avez des gens plus âgés qui vous encouragent à
un jeune âge et que vous savez que c'est comme
rendre les gens fiers de vous pour avoir fait
quelque chose que vous voulez faire, alors nous
voulions  être en mesure de voir si nous pouvons prendre
ce type de système qui nous a été enseigné
et c'est à nous de pouvoir aider
les enfants de toute la ville dans toute la ville,
beaucoup de gens ne réalisent pas qu'il a fallu
la musique de la Nouvelle-Orléans pour aller  là-bas faites
savoir à tout le monde que c'est quelque chose
qui va nous manquer si nous allons
reconstruire et nous remettre ensemble
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait disparaître
c'est pourquoi la musique la musique est si importante
à préserver et vous connaissez cette culture
parce que maintenant nous donnons  de retour à ces
enfants qui vont le transmettre à leurs
enfants ils le transmettent à leurs amis
et gardent la musique vivante si je sauve la
vie d'une personne grâce à la musique mon
point fort j'ai fait mon travail nous prenons toutes
les nationalités toutes différentes sortes de
saveurs ou  des sentiments différents et nous
l'avons juste mis ensemble et tout ce que nous
proposons et c'est ce que
tout à la Nouvelle-Orléans, je me fiche de
ce que c'est, de la musique à l'imbécile à juste
traîner avec les gars
[Musique]
ça remonte à loin  depuis le tout
début de la ville, c'était une ville portuaire,
donc les navires montaient et descendaient la rivière
et traversaient l'océan toujours il y avait un
grand mélange de gens et donc je pense que la
musique est venue avec ça avec le
mélange de gens
[Musique]
nous jouons comme si nous vivions nous jouions comme si nous
dansions donc c'est généralement vous frappez comme si vous
pouviez entendre un musicien de la Nouvelle-Orléans partout dans
le monde où que ce soit quand vous mettez
ce disque de Louis Armstrong avec cette
trompette vous pouvez entendre qu'il a
quelque chose là-bas  qu'aucun d'entre nous n'a
jamais été capable d'expliquer qu'il suffit d'
être ici cela devient un mode de vie
maintenant c'est notre industrie semble être
la culture la musique et l'art et la nourriture ce qui je
pense est un très bon endroit pour avoir
des spécialités
[Musique]